die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann mit viel fußball genannt
ein kleiner hoffnungsschimmer kommt
heute aus istanbul
überraschende ankündigung russland
verspricht bei ukraine gesprächen man
werde die militärischen aktivitäten rund
um kiew drastisch herunterfahren
risiko lieferstopp ohne öl und gas aus
russland drohen der deutschen wirtschaft
dramatische ausfälle warnen verbände
und ende der schonzeit bundestrainer
flick bekommt beim wm-test gegen holland
nach acht eher leichten gegnern die
erste harte nuss zu knacken
offenbar hat sich bei den verhandlungen
in istanbul mehr bewegt als erwartet die
türkischen vermittler zumindest sprechen
von deutlichen schritten richtung
kriegsende die ukraine ist bereits um
neutralität wenn ihre sicherheit von
anderen staaten garantiert wird das
russische verteidigungsministerium
kündigte an in kiew die
militäraktivitäten zu reduzieren
ungeachtet dessen setzt russland
allerdings seine bombardierungen und
angriffe fort aus istanbul berichtet
league pott
die erwartungen waren hoch nach fünf
wochen blutigen krieg in der ukraine
sollte endlich eine basis für eine
tragfähige waffenruhe gefunden werden
dazu forderte der gastgeber türkeis
präsident erdogan seine gäste dringend
auf beim
aktuellen stand der verhandlungen
tragen sie als delegationen eine große
historische verantwortung
die gesamte welt wartet auf eine gute
nachricht von ihnen
tatsächlich gab es ein neues
verhandlungsangebot der ukraine das land
ist bereit auf einen nato beitritt zu
verzichten und neutralität status zu
akzeptieren aber nur unter vorher
international vereinbarten klaren
sicherheitsgarantien die müssten von den
un sicherheitsratsmitgliedern kommen
aber auch die türkei polen deutschland
und andere länder sind eingeladen diesem
abkommen beizutreten
auch über die krim über lohans und dort
könne man reden so das angebot der
ukraine gebietsabtretungen seien aber
indiskutabel für
uns gelten nach wie vor die
international festgelegten grenzen von
1991 da gibt es keine kompromisse
trotzdem nannte die russische seite die
gespräche konstruktiv und kündigte eine
geste des guten willens an
das verteidigungsministerium hat
beschlossen die militärischen
aktivitäten in kiew von cerny in
erheblichem maße einzuschränken man
werde die vorschläge der ukraine jetzt
präsident putin in moskau zur beratung
vorlegen einen neuen verhandlungstermin
gibt es noch nicht
fragen wir wieder jörg brase in lemberg
trauen die menschen in der ukraine den
ankündigen russ ankündigungen russlands
nein das tun sie nicht also wir haben
heute mit vielen hier in lemberg
gesprochen die alle einhellig gesagt
haben dass sie diesen zusagen nicht
vertrauen ganz im gegenteil sie erwarten
dass dieser krieg wahrscheinlich noch
lange anhalten könnte sie sagen von
russischer seite haben wir bisher nur
lügen gehört und auch was die
ankündigung angeht truppen um hier vor
der jhv abzuziehen da sagen einige das
könnte auch ein trick sein diese truppen
könnten an anderer stelle wieder
auftauchen diese skepsis die wird
gestützt durch das was heute auf dem
schlachtfeld passiert denn das land sei
heute die härtesten angriffe seit vielen
tagen das gilt vor allem für die städte
im süden und dem osten aber
offensichtlich wurden auch wieder
nachschub stellungen angegriffen wir
haben gehört dass es der ukrainischen
luftabwehr gelungen sein soll zwei
raketen abzufangen die auf ziele ganz in
der nähe hiervon lemberg gerichtet waren
große skepsis also in der ukraine vielen
dank jörg brase war das live aus lemberg
mit dem zurückfahren der kampfhandlungen
wolle russland vertrauen aufbauen das
sagte der russische vize
verteidigungsminister nach dem treffen
in istanbul
möglicherweise kommt der teilrückzug
moskau aber auch einfach sehr gelegen
weil die eigenen truppen nicht so
erfolgreich voran kommen wie erwartet
luton leinhos und markus töpfer über die
lage im kriegsgebiet
dass russlands truppen sich aus der
hauptstadtregion zurückziehen auf der
straße von kiew nach ihre bienen ist es
bereits zu spüren wochenlang galt sie
als eine straße des todes diesmal kommt
der krankenwagen problemlos durch und
wird schon sehnsüchtig erwartet
wir konnten einfach nicht flüchten von
ihr weil wir immer und überall
geschossen wurden
doch die evakuierungs mission bleibt
gefährlich denn die angriffe aus der
luft gehen vorerst weiter am boden aber
habe man die russischen truppen
vertrieben
es gibt gute nachrichten unsere
verteidiger in kiew kommen voran und
holen ukrainisches territorium zurück im
team ist befreit gut gemacht
im moment ist unklar ob russland seine
einsätze um kiew und jenny hilft
tatsächlich tief greifend einschränken
will oder ob moskaus truppen sich
zurückziehen müssen wie dies offenbar
gerade nahe der städte aktiv und trost
ja netz geschieht
die ukrainische armee hat rost ja netz
nach einschätzung der us regierung
zurück erobert auch bilder der
nachrichtenagentur ap zeigen ukrainische
soldaten auf panzern die von der
bevölkerung begrüßt werden
östlich der schwer zerstörten
millionenstadt gemeldet kiew ebenfalls
erfolge über die russische armee dabei
soll es in der ortschaft malaga zu
schwerwiegenden racheakten gekommen sein
aufnahmen im online-dienst telegramm
zeigen männer im russischen
militäruniformen gefesselt am boden als
ein gefangener nach einem offizier fragt
mit ihm und anderen in die beine
geschossen
eine verletzung der genfer konvention
die die menschliche behandlung von
kriegsgefangenen vor schreibt die
regierung in kiew reagiert
wir behandeln das mit härte es wird
untersucht wir verhöhnen keine
gefangenen wir sind eine europäische
armee ein europäischer staat
russland will seine kriegsführung nun
vor allem auf die selbsternannten
volksrepublik in lugansk und donets
konzentrieren und sich über mario pohl
eine landbrücke zur krim verschaffen
alle männer die die schwer zerstörte
stadt am schwarzen meer heute verlassen
wollten wurden von russischen
separatisten auf mögliche ss tattoos
überprüft die entnazifizierung der
ukraine hat präsident gut hin zum
wichtigen kriegsziel erklärt
die menschenrechtslage in der ukraine
hat auch amnesty international im blick
im jahresbericht wird die organisation
der russischen armee kriegsverbrechen
vor russland attackiere gezielt zivile
einrichtungen und verwandle fluchtrouten
in so wörtlich todesfallen amnesty hat
nach eigenen angaben zahlreiche angriffe
auf krankenhäuser schulen und
wohngebiete wie hier in mariupol
dokumentiert amnesty international
spricht sich dafür aus die
internationale strafverfolgung zu
stärken um die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen
diese krieg in der ukraine wirft auch
noch eine ganz andere frage auf was
bedeuten die angriffe für die sicherheit
der atomkraftwerke im land der chef der
internationalen
atomenergiebehörde bietet technische
unterstützung an um die gefahr eines
nuklearen unfalls so klein wie möglich
zu halten in der provinz rift liegt
eines der fünf ukrainischen akw jörg
brase war dort
das kernkraftwerk hüfner liegt nur
wenige kilometer von der russischen
grenze entfernt russland nutzt belarus
als abschussbasis von raketen richtung
ukraine
das kraftwerk liegt mitten im schussfeld
über die hälfte des eigenen
energiebedarfs deckt die ukraine mit
kernkraft und zwei der fünf ukrainischen
atomanlagen sind bereits von russlands
militärs besetzt
wir können uns zwar nicht vorstellen
dass sie tatsächlich auch unsere
atomanlage besetzen werden aber wir
müssen uns darauf vorbereiten und wir
werden alles versuchen unser land unsere
energieproduktion und unser kraftwerk zu
verteidigen
die mitarbeiter und ihre familien
40.000 menschen leben in der atom- stadt
war rasch dort erinnert ein denkmal an
die katastrophe von tschernobyl vor 36
jahren in was glauben sie an die
sicherheit der atomenergie doch ein
krieg ein angriff auf ihr kraftwerk das
konnten sie sich bis vor kurzem noch
nicht vorstellen
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
und her groß sie sagen es sei alles
unter kontrolle
aber das ist eine lüge ich weiß dass
meine kollegen aus tschechien
vorgeschlagen haben das internationale
friedenstruppen der vereinten nationen
an den atom standorten stationiert
werden sollten natürlich ohne die
beteiligung russland
sie haben angst packen care pakete für
die eigenen soldaten an der front und
sie hoffen dass dieser krieg bald vorbei
sein wird und ihr atomkraftwerk
unbeschädigt bleibt
der streit um russische gaslieferungen
und deren bezahlung dauert an die
russische regierung droht mit einem
lieferstopp wenn nicht künftig in rubel
bezahlt wird das jedoch lehnen
deutschland und andere staaten ab die
industrie in deutschland ist alarmiert
denn sie ist die größte der größte
erdgas verbraucher mit 36 prozent etwas
weniger 31 geht an die haushalte
kraftwerke verbrauchten für strom und
fernwärme 21 prozent handel und
dienstleistungen 12 prozent was passiert
wenn russland tatsächlich den gashahn
zudrehen würde zeigt heiko rams
noch laufen sie ohne probleme die werke
der chemischen industrie wie hier im
chempark in leverkusen doch wenn kein
russisches gas mehr strömt könnte sich
das schnell ändern der branchenverband
warnt das hätte dramatische auswirkungen
auf unsere großen energieintensiven
unternehmen vor allen dingen aber auch
die ganze bandbreite des mittelstandes
aber es kommt noch ein indirekter infekt
hinzu chemie steht am anfang aller
produktionsprozesse in deutschland das
heißt keine chemie heißt in der
konsequenz auch die lieferketten brechen
die produktionsketten brechen zusammen
das hat massive auswirkungen auf alle
branchen automobil auf bauindustrie auf
pharmaindustrie auch der verband der
stahlindustrie schlägt alarm wenn es
hier zu einem importstopp für
erdgaslieferungen kommt dann können die
produktionsprozesse in der
stahlindustrie nicht weiterlaufen da
erdgas kurzfristig nicht substituierbar
ist und wenn dieser produktionsstopp
ohne ausreichende vorbereitungszeit
kommt und führt das herunterfahren der
anlage auch zu der gefahr dass bis zu
schäden kommt die unterirdischen
gasspeicher in deutschland sind ziemlich
leer die gasreserven sollen nur noch bis
zum herbst reichen wenn der nachschub
weiter fehlt schreitet die
bundesnetzagentur ein sie setzt einen
notfallplan um zuerst gibt es eine frühe
warnstufe dann die alarm und als letztes
die notfall stufe die behörde kann zum
beispiel industriekunden vom netz nehmen
oder anordnen dass endverbraucher ihren
verbrauch reduzieren
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck warnt
heute in berlin jedoch auch vor den
folgen für ärmere länder bestimmte
produkte werden vielleicht nicht mehr
ausreichend produziert werden können
düngemittel zum beispiel brauchen viel
gas fehlt das gas haben wir
möglicherweise einen verlust an den
mengen an düngemitteln die wir brauchen
um die welternährung
zu stellen die konsequenzen der
gasknappheit drohen also nicht nur
europa sondern weltweit
was wir alle im vergangenen jahr gespürt
haben gibt es jetzt schwarz auf weiß vom
deutschen wetterdienst der sommer war zu
nass der herbst zu trocken es war das
elfte jahr in folge zu warm die
durchschnittstemperatur lag bei 9,2 grad
und damit um knapp ein grad über dem
durchschnittswert von
1961 bis 1990 auch wetterextremen armen
zu beispielsweise die schweren
überschwemmungen in rheinland pfalz und
nordrhein westfalen im vergangenen
sommer
wie der klimawandel unser wetter
verändert mehr dazu finden sie in
unserer zdf heute app dort können sie
zum beispiel nachlesen wie und warum der
wald besonders unter dem anstieg der
treibhausgase leidet jetzt zu corona ab
sonntag gelten nur noch wenige
schutzregeln masken pflicht an
bestimmten orten zum beispiel und tests
in kliniken und pflegeheimen die meisten
bundesländer verzichten nun darauf
zunächst mit sogenannten hot spots
regelung die maßnahmen wieder zu
verschärfen weil ihnen dafür
rechtssichere kriterien fehlten das
robert koch institut meldet
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 15
1272 mehr als vor einer woche 307
todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben tage
incidents steigt leicht auf
1.700 3,3
wohnungen werden hierzulande immer mehr
zur mangelware die preise hoch das
angebot knapp deshalb will die
bundesregierung ja jedes jahr
400.000 neue bauen doch gibt es dafür
ausreichend bauland
ja sagt eine studie die die
bundesregierung heute vorgelegt hat in
städten und gemeinden stünden flächen
von fast 100.000 hektar zur verfügung
und darauf könnten bis zu zwei millionen
wohnungen errichtet werden doch einfach
wird das nicht jan frederik fischer
in schwäbisch gmünd ist der bau in
vollem gange ganze 147 mietwohnungen
sollen hier entstehen die landes
baugenossenschaft württemberg hatte
glück sie konnte bauland ergattern also
in ballungszentren ist es fast unmöglich
bauland für bezahlbares wohnen zu finden
weil sehr viel wettbewerber da sind die
ja investieren möchten um die
angespannte lage zu entschärfen plant
die ampel koalition jährlich 400.000
wohnungen zu bauen doch zuletzt war
unklar wie viel potenzielles bauland
überhaupt existiert heute die antwort es
gibt genug und nicht immer muss bei
neuen bauvorhaben auf freie flächen
ausgewichen werden wir stehen zu unserem
ziel flächen in deutschland weniger in
anspruch zu nehmen als das bisher der
fall war wir können es uns nämlich
sowohl ökonomisch als auch ökologisch
nicht mehr leisten flächen zu
verschwenden eine lösung nach
verdichtungen heißt stockwerke werden
auf alte draufgesetzt doch längst geht
es nicht mehr nur um freie flächen
sondern grundsätzlich darum ob es sich
überhaupt noch lohnt zu bauen denn die
kosten explodieren die gründe hohe
bauauflagen fehlende fachkräfte und vor
allem ein steigender mangel an
baumaterialien ja haben bei uns auf
mehreren baustellen schon deutlich
verzögerung der jetzigen aktivitäten wir
müssen auch produktionsstätten wieder
wenn sie systemrelevant sind bei uns im
kernbereich von europa auch in
deutschland aktivieren die
bundesregierung hat sich beim
wohnungsbau ehrgeizige ziele gesetzt
doch die umsetzung wird auch durch
globale entwicklung schwieriger als
gedacht
noch kurz ein blick nach london weil die
beerdigung von prinz philip vor einem
jahr corona bedingt nur im kleinen kreis
stattfand wurde heute ein
gedenkgottesdienst für ihn nachgeholt in
anwesenheit seiner witwe queen elizabeth
der zweite
prinz philip war am 9 april im alter von
99 jahren gestorben
die queen kam trotz ihrer angeschlagenen
gesundheit zur zeremonie in die
westminster abbey es war der erste
größere auftritt der 95-jährigen seit
ihrer corona infektion
beeindruckende alte dame keiner sagen
bevor jetzt fußball heute in amsterdam
deutschland gegangen und das ist ja auch
das duell zweier trainer mit bayern
vergangenheit hansi flick gar noch gar
nicht so lange her und oranje coach
louis van gaal der ja von 2009 bis 2011
den fcb trainierte zwei erfolgreiche
meistermacher mit großem gegenseitigem
respekt
der 70 jahre alte taktik fuchs louis van
gaal hätte gerne gegen ein team in
bestbesetzung gespielt doch hansi flick
vielen neuen spieler das ist ein jammer
viele deutsche spieler sind verletzt das
ist schade für das testspiel in seiner
zeit als bayern trainer förderte er
thomas müller für den er nur lobende
worte findet premiere ist es peter
müller ist ein spieler der vorne stark
ist aber auch schlau verteidigt er ist
für jeden trainer ein idealer spiel
bei der personalie müller hat er noch
einen tipp für seinen kollegen wenn ich
flieg wäre würde ich müller aufstellen
mich sehr motiviert sein wird
typisch van gaal der sich nach seinem
rad anblick einen grinsen nicht
verkneifen kann
heute abend noch weitere länderspiele
und da geht es um richtig was nämlich um
zwei tickets für die fußball wm im
finale der playoffs trifft polen auf
schweden und portugal mit weltstar
ronaldo auf nord mazedonien
ja und die deutsche u 21
nationalmannschaft die hat vor wenigen
minuten einen großen schritt in richtung
em ticket gemacht im auswärtsspiel beim
ärgsten verfolger israel gewann der
tabellenführer mit 1 0
kapitän julian burkhart verletzt sich
beim aufwärmen in petach tikva bei tel
aviv die dfb nachwuchsauswahl in den
dunklen trikots kommt so geschwächt zum
0 0 zur halbzeit trifft aber zuerst nach
einer stunde 1 0 durch chlor katterbach
sein erstes tor für die u21 vorarbeit
jan thielmann das team von antonio di
salvo fürht die em qualifikationsgruppe
2 vor israel an das spitzenspiel hier um
die tabellenführung bringen sie über die
zeit es bleibt beim 1 0 die deutsche
mannschaft macht einen großen schritt
zur u21 em endrunde im nächsten jahr in
georgien und rumänien
das was vom sportcenter schön dass
früher war bislang viel zu trocken
morgen ändert sich das schauer und
gewitter sind unterwegs mehr dazu hat
gleich aus dem verlies marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn im heute
journal
danke für ihr interesse das gesamte 19
uhr team wünscht ihnen noch einen guten
abend bis morgen wenn sie würden auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter mit eisigen grüßen
geht es in dieser woche weiter mit dem
wetter denn aus dem norden kommt die
luft hier sehen sie die südspitze von
spitzbergen und wenn diese eisige luft
masse aus der arktis über relativ warmes
wasser zieht dann bilden sich diese
wolken straßen das sieht dann so aus
wenn man es fotografiert und von norden
von spitzbergen aus kommt die eisige
luft weiter richtung deutschland voran
noch ist dieses tiefe aktiv bringt regen
zieht weiter aber den nächsten tagen
setzt sich diese kaltluft durch in der
nacht gibt es mit diesem tief regen im
süden sonst teilweise aufgelockert und
auch im nordwesten einige tropfen dass
bei tiefsten temperaturen von minus zwei
grad im osten und 10 grad im südwesten
deutschlands morgen dann viele wolken
mit regen und schnee in den bergen sogar
gewitter sind dabei hier und da auch mal
sonnenschein richtung ostsee ist ja auch
etwas schnee unterwegs bei temperaturen
von 4 grad im vogtland und 15 grad im
süden maximal hier ist die wärmere
luftmassen noch vorhanden der blick auf
die nächsten tage ja es wird allmählich
kühler regen und schnee am donnerstag
bei vier bis elf grad temperaturen am
samstag dann nur noch bei minus ein bis
plus zehn grad und schneefall an den
alpen schöner abend